Religion du monde Véronique
Guémard. Le Kenya est encore
sous le choc du massacre de
Chakaola, le bilan dépasse
désormais les trois-00 morts.
Le pasteur d'une secte
évangélique préconisait le
jeûne jusqu'à la mort à ses
adeptes pour rencontrer Jésus.
Dans ce pays d'Afrique de l'Est
où la majorité des habitants
sont chrétiens, l'offre
religieuse est immense, mais
comment la réguler? Religion du
monde, Véronique Guémard.
Dimanche à partir de 9h10 DU.
RFI.
Rfi et France 24 présentent
Radio FOOT International, le
Café des sports, Annie Gasnier.
Bonjou
r à tous et merci d'être
au rendez-vous du Café des
Sports. comme chaque semaine et
fidèlement et que ce soit euh,
grâce au son ou grâce à
l'image, vous pouvez nous
suivre donc vous êtes fidèles
euh, l'actualité euh, est en
train de de devenir plus maigre
mais on a encore plein de
choses à se dire vous allez
voir et nos invités les plus
fidèles sont là aussi, bonjour
Rémy bonjour euh, Annie je suis
essoufflée parce que j'ai passé
le temps à porter Xavier Barret
qui a un pied de Neymar
aujourd'hui à genou Neymar oui
bonjour à tous. Avec une petite
entorse. Ouais bon. Mais il est
là et c'est le principal et il
est là à l'heure. Et puis
l'homme des réseaux sociaux,
l'homme aux yeux bleus il est
là aussi. Attendez il y a plus
de balles jaunes à Paris en ce
moment, alors il est avec nous.
Bonjour. Qui chat qui a les
yeux bleus là aussi sur la page
Facebook? Oui oui c'est une
innovation qui une petite
mascotte. Tout va bien Frédéric
ils sont ils sont là nos nos
nos fidèles euh suiveurs euh
Neymar Barcelone font dévoilent
pas tout mais ça réagit déjà.
Le quatrième homme alors?
Quatrième homme, eh bien euh
vous connaissez surtout sa voix
mais il est aujourd'hui là en
personne et non pas
virtuellement dans ce studio.
Bonjour François David
. Bonjour Annie, bonjour à
tous. Notre correspondant, si
fidèle en Espagne et qui est
basé à Barcelone. Et justement
euh on a pensé à vous euh
François pour euh les sujets du
jour et nous parlerons d'abord
de Neymar. Neymar à nouveau au
centre du projet parisien.
C'est ce qu'on peut se
demander. En tout cas le retour
en grâce de la star brésilienne
semble avoir un nom, un par un,
un papa Luis Henrique, le
probable futur c'est du PSG
semble vouloir miser sur cet
attaquant qu'il a si bien connu
au Barça pour lui redonner le
goût du jeu, de l'enjeu aussi
euh, à Paris, au PSG et
peut-être aussi en sélection le
numéro dix manque cruellement.
Le Barça de retour au top. Les
enfin sacrés champions de la
Liga après quatre années
difficiles. Grâce sans doute à
leur entraîneur icône du club
catalan, Xavi qui a rebâti une
belle équipe, l'avenir leur
sourit-il désormais aussi en
Europe. La colère d'un
capitaine, le grand Thibaut
Courtois a refusé de jouer avec
la Belgique cette semaine à
cause dit-on d'un brassard tour
et donc d'avoir été rétrogradé
au sein des Diables Rouges. Le
gardien a-t-il raison ou tort?
Eh bien ces questions nous
essaierons d'y répondre dans le
café des sports préparés avec
l'aide de David Finzel, Pierre
Guérin, Laurence qui est à la à
la réalisation excusez-moi. Il
y a aussi Souheil Khedir et
Yann Bourdelas pour les moyens
vidéo. Le Café des sports alors
les débats sont ouverts mais je
voudrais avant on peut
souhaiter un bon anniversaire
aujourd'hui parce qu'on est le
23 juin, Zinédine Zidane. 51
ans, Zinédine Zedane, merci
Zizou, bon anniversaire.
La petite voix de Neymar était
à ses débuts lorsqu'il avait
débarqué à Paris le fameux été
2017. Alors euh Neymar danse
sans doute très bien à la samba
hein comme la plupart des des
Brésiliens mais sur quel pied
danse-t-il ces jours-ci alors
qu'il se remet apparemment
plutôt bien d'une grave
blessure à la cheville droite
qu'il avait subi à la Coupe du
monde euh c'était dans le match
on s'en souvient au Qatar face
à la Serbie et qui avait donné
lieu à une opération euh une
chirurgie c'était le 10 mars
euh dernier. Restez ou pas donc
euh c'est la possibilité qui
s'offre à lui, on avait
l'impression que le club avait
un petit peu l'envie de le
mettre sur la touche, on
l'annonçait du côté de
l'Angleterre mais l'arrivée
probable d'un entraîneur
espagnol justement Luis Enrique
au PSG pourrait rebât
un tout jeune Brésilien, vous
vous en souvenez il était tout
jeune, il était euh encore euh
presque pas fini mais en tout
cas il venait c'est déjà avec
son aura de grands joueurs euh
brésiliens et il avait remporté
avec euh cette équipe euh
pendant les deux ans où il a
travaillé avec euh euh Luis
Henrique, ils avaient remporté
la euh Ligue des champions euh
face à la Juventus, on s'en
souvient. Alors, est-il parti
pour rester, je vais d'abord
poser peut-être la question à à
Xavier, est-il parti pour
rester euh on sait, il a un
contrat jusqu'en
deux-mille-vingt-sept, et on
croyait comprendre qu'il avait
pas trop envie de bouger en
plus euh cette euh la saison En
même temps il fait un peu ce
qu'il veut à Paris hein euh ou
à Bougival dans sa dans sa
villa luxueuse, il organise des
fêtes jusqu'à Point d'Heure, ce
qui incommode euh certains
voisins. Il joue au poste au
poker, il se balade, il rentre
à Barcelone quand il en a
envie, il va au Brésil, donc il
fait un peu ce qu'il veut, dans
une ville euh qui est quand
même bien agréable à vivre, et
où il y a toujours eu beaucoup
de Brésiliens, c'est une
tradition au Paris
Saint-Germain, il y a des
joueurs brésiliens, donc il est
pas tout seul. Donc euh Neymar
c'est pas nouveau que le Paris
Saint-Germain aimerait le
vendre, mais euh l'an dernier
quand ils ont cherché à s'en
débarrasser pour parler euh,
crûment personne n'en a voulu,
pour deux raisons, d'abord pour
cette réputation un peu
sulfureuse et aussi pour le
coup de son salaire qui est
exorbitant euh, donc surtout
qu'il joue à peu près un match
sur deux, seulement donc euh,
euh, du coup euh, le Paris
Saint-Germain qui n'a pas
renouvelé Messi et qui risque
de perdre Mbappé bah, il n'en
reste plus qu'un seul choix
c'est de garder Neymar avec qui
ils ont un contrat de longue
durée. Alors selon nos
confrères euh, du journal Le
Parisien euh, François David
euh, il y aurait eu des
contacts déjà puisque euh,
apparemment on en est au stade
de la négociation euh, du
contrat de Luis Enrique serait
donc le futur entraîneur et les
deux hommes, Neymar et Luis
Enrique se seraient déjà
parlés. Est-ce que euh Luis
Henrique doit euh ou peu euh
miser sur euh sur Neymar même
si ce n'est évidemment plus le
Neymar qu'il a connu euh si je
me trompe pas, ça fait 8 ans
quand même hein la la victoire
en en Ligue des champions déjà.
Neymar il va sur ses 32 ans si
je me trompe pas euh avec le
passif de tout ce qu'a dit Xavi
et que les blessures, le euh
l'énorme salaire, l'avantage.
On l'a vu brillant en début de
saison dernière, juste avant la
coupe du monde. Oui donc il
avait il a gardé quand même pas
vu très brillant non plus la
Coupe du monde non plus.
Blessé? Bah euh blessé au
deuxième match. On on a un qui
nous rappelle qu'il était le
meilleur joueur parisien euh à
l'automne hein effectivement
avec Messi aussi. Maintenant
oui, ils se connaissent, ils se
connaissent, ça c'est
l'avantage. Euh cinéma reste au
Paris Saint-Germain Normal.
Normal. Neymar s'entend pas
très très bien avec tous ses
entraîneurs et ça a jamais été
le cas. Avec Luis Cédric
j'avais une relation normale.
Il le faisait jouer et il lui
donnait quelques
responsabilités, ça lui
suffisait. C'était grand amour
non plus, ce n'est pas une
filiation comme avec d'autres
joueurs. Euh mais il y avait la
gagne aussi que Et puis surtout
il est encadré par Messi qui
était son son ami et son idole
et Luis Suarez qui étaient une
forte euh personnalité. Chose
qu'il a pas à Paris. Maintenant
il y avait aussi Jordi Alba, il
y avait aussi des des joueurs
très importants dans le
vestiaire. Il était en il était
encadré. Il arrivait comme un
junior, vous l'avez rappelé,
Annie euh là euh c'est c'est le
patron de l'équipe, surtout si
euh quand même. Ben si Mbappé
reste pas. Ah ben euh ce sera
ça, ce sera ça le patron et je
pense que le ce que lui dit
Luis Enrique lui dit est-ce que
t'es prêt aujourd'hui à montrer
l'exemple? Et c'est un peu la
question que tout le monde se
pose parce que le talent de de
Neymar on en est tous
convaincus, vous rappelez
effectivement son bel automne.
On peut rappeler aussi comment
il a amené le Paris
Saint-Germain en finale de la
Ligue des champions il y a en
en 20vingt Oui, mais mais quand
il veut, c'est un joueur
extraordinaire. Le problème
c'est que c'est trop intermis
il a pas été décisif tant que
chaque fois non plus en en
Ligue des champions avec le PSG
euh je suis pas pour répondre à
votre question précisément que
vous avez posé à Xavi er euh je
suis pas sûr moi qui va rester
au PSG je suis pas sûr. Alors
aujourd'hui je suis pas sûr et
ça dépendra aussi de ce que
fait Kylian Mbappé euh dans les
semaines à venir. Rémy pour
vous le le Paris Saint-Germain
doit-il encore miser euh sur ce
joueur? On le sait euh il est
là depuis cinq ans, il a été
plutôt intermittent mais
surtout à cause de blessures
après bon d'où viennent les
blessures, ça c' notre sujet
mais en tout cas euh on on il
est il est doué euh, on le sait
euh, il éclaire le jeu, il a
peut-être manqué cette saison
d'ailleurs au Paris
Saint-Germain en fin de saison?
Je crois que la vie et tout ce
qu'il a fait aujourd'hui dans
que ce soit au Barça c'est
l'espoir et le désespoir. Il
faut savoir que quand Neymar
arrive au Barça le Barça sort
d'une saison d'humiliation en
encaissant sept buts face au
Bayern Ligue des champions
quatre et trois zéro. C'est en
sept ans que il y a un grand
chamboulement où justement
recèle décide de s'élancer dans
l'asso ou d'ailleurs cette
histoire va la mort aussi d'un
de l'entraîneur. Il y avait
beaucoup de circonstances il y
avait ça il a accueilli comme
une rock star que parce que
déjà il est présenté presque
avant même que ça ne soit.
Surtout on avait la sensation
que le PSG l'avait volé
finalement euh ça d'une
certaine manière, même en le
payant mais c'était une prise
de guerre.
Deux-cent-vingt-deux-millions
vous savez que Rémy Genot il
parle toujours que des temps
anciens. Donc euh déjà ce Barça
là il faut se dire que Neymar
avait déçu. Pourquoi est-ce
qu'il avait déçu? Parce qu'on
disait que il ne s'adaptait pas
parce qu'il n'avait que 64
kilos et demi, il fallait qu'il
retrouve un peu de la forme.
Après on a dit qu'il avait les
amygdales, on a fait une
opération d'amygdale. Euh il
perdu sept kilos, après
maintenant quand il prenait un
peu de poids, cette fois-ci
c'était les jambes. Maintenant
quand on disait que les jambes
sont déjà guéries, cette
fois-ci c'était la recul, quand
on disait que c'était la
rotule, maintenant c'était les
orteils donc bref c'est un
grand corps malade, c'est ça le
problème avec Neymar
c'est-à-dire que chaque fois on
se dit Neymar en train de
partir, après stop, Neymar
s'arrête, il n'y a jamais eu
une saison de façon continue
parce que même si on voit les
mais même quand voit justement
ce Barça de qui où il va quand
même gagner huit trophées dont
une Ligue des champions on se
rend quand même compte que
Neymar n'était pas la clé de
voûte, Neymar n'était pas aussi
important que ça, mais c'était
un groupe qui était beaucoup
plus important que Neymar alors
qu'on attendait qui devait
vraiment apporter de la
lumière. Mais j'ai cependant vu
un Neymar peut-être qui avec
l'absence de Messi avec le
relais et tout le monde disait
c'est bon il va cette fois-ci
un ballon d'or, la preuve
d'ailleurs c'est que
aujourd'hui moi je vois que
Neymar a été décroissant le
Neymar d'aujourd'hui. Le Neymar
d'aujourd'hui n'en vaut même
pas celui du Brésil qui était
déjà dans le top 5 du Ballon
d'or. Le Neymar d'aujourd'hui
n'aime pas dans le top dix, le
Neymar d'aujourd'hui n'est même
pas actuellement capable de
pouvoir mener l'équipe du
Brésil qui compte sur Venus.
Moi je crois que le Neymar
d'aujourd'hui, la première des
choses qu'il faut d'abord c'est
d'abord une discipline
tactique. Est-ce qu'il est
capable lorsqu'on connaît le
système d'Enriké? Le système
d'Enriké c'est le pressing.
C'est le pressing à outrance
quatre trois. Justement Neymar
aujourd'hui, qu'est-ce qu'on
avait avec le PSG? Le PSG les
trois de demain ne pressaient
pas. Il y en a un qui dit
pressé c'était Neymar qui
pressait le plus. Non Neymar
il ne pouvait pas continuer. Je
suis pas d'accord avec Rémy
Gonot non mais il y a il y a un
vrai problème parce que c'est
les blessures, tout ça, on
connaît l'histoire. Mais on l'a
vu lors de la dernière coupe du
monde. Neymar c'est d'abord
dans au mental que ça se joue.
Parce que à la dernière coupe
du monde il est blessé au
deuxième match mais il fait
tout pour revenir et pour jouer
le le quart de finale, il le
perd effectivement aux tirs au
but mais il le joue. Et il
marque Neymar
à le motiver quand on arrive à
le mobiliser pour un objectif,
il est présent, blessé ou pas.
Et c'est ça le au PSG c'est que
ces dernières années eh ben dès
qu'il était blessé allez la
saison est terminée je rentre
chez moi. Il y avait pas
d'entraîneur capable de le
sur-motiver. Est-ce que Luis
Enrique va retrouver les mots
qu'il avait pu trouver à son
arrivé à Barcelone pour le
relancer au PSG c'est tout
l'intérêt de cette euh nouvelle
association. Moi je me dis
pourquoi pas qui est pas pour
moi n'est pas gagné. Pour pour
moi n'est pas gagné. Moi je
suis vraiment pas sûr que
Neymar va rester. Neymar a
besoin d'être trop dur? Parce
que il a je pense que euh
pour retrouver le vrai Neymar,
je pense que Neymar a besoin
d'être responsabilisé et de
sentir la star vraiment de
l'équipe, comme il l'a été au
Brésil un moment, comme il
était au début au PSG quand
Mbappé était euh était encore
tout jeune, je pense il y a
vraiment besoin, ils ont il a
très vite fait de l'ombre en
fait euh en plus pour
l'histoire des penaltys euh à
sa place je pense qu'un départ
moi je pense que serait une des
meilleures euh solutions et euh
l'histoire de pénalty c'était
entre Neymar et Cavani. Oui. Et
c'est devenu Neymar
qui les Rémy vous vous parlez
de la la où effectivement il y
a il y a Vincent mais en même
temps on l'a vu cette
sélescente du Brésil cette
semaine euh perdre face euh au
Sénégal, elle avait perdu aussi
face au Maroc alors okay on est
dans le cadre de matchs amicaux
mais euh elle a gagné contre la
la Guinée mais on a la
sensation, on a parlé cette
semaine euh beaucoup du du
Brésil dans Radio Foot et on a
on a la sensation qui manque
quand même l'étincelle Neymar
dans dans dans ce groupe où il
y a par ailleurs de très bons
joueurs. Il manque euh
certainement euh Neymar mais on
pourrait aussi dire que euh il
manque justement ce qu'on peut
ça on l'a déjà dit aussi.
Voilà, c'est ça. C'est d'abord
ça. Et puis je crois que cette
équipe du Brésil aujourd'hui
n'est pas aussi clinique que
ça, parce qu'il n'y a pas aussi
un grand buteur. Au niveau de
cette équipe du Brésil, donc ça
fait un véritable problème.
Donc moi je pense que Neymar
pouvait bien manquer à cette
rencontre-là, mais on se rend
quand même compte que ce n'est
pas à la fois qu'ils perdent
également, ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'ils déçoivent
et d'ailleurs même ils ont été
battus par le Cameroun. Donc
aujourd'hui l'Afrique est
devenue plutôt le maître à
jouer du Brésil. C'est-à-dire
que généralement on avait on
avait peur du Brésil
maintenant, c'est toutes les
équipes africaines qui tabasent
au Brésil. Oui. Donc pour la
coupe du monde le Cameroun a
battu le Brésil. C'était un
match sans danger. Au Cameroun
Sénégal dans une belle série.
C'est une belle série!
Attendez. C'est vrai. Donc pour
moi aujourd'hui je crois que
cette équipe-là manque
sélectionneur et plutôt moi je
crois une seconde parce que je
crois qu'il y a pas mal de
réactions les messages sur le
Facebook live euh, Nabo
Fortuné, Neymar pour être au
top il faut qu'il laisse de
côté euh, bah son côté
bling-bling il aime trop la vie
ce gamin alors que le foot ne
ment jamais euh, Guin Zoda
Neymar ferait mieux de
rejoindre la vague d'Arabie
euh, saoudite hein, comprenez
et rejoindre les les christian
euh Messi et et consorts. Non
non pas Messieurs. Bon ben
c'est un petit peu la pré
retraite également hein. Euh
Youssouf Elarif, il est aux
Comores avec Luis Henrique, je
sais que le PSG va retrouver
son identité, pour Neymar c'est
plus préoccupant, son hygiène
de vie euh un message encore
archéduc, j'ai aimé Neymar
surtout grâce à ses cheveux
pour le jeu, c'est autre chose.
C'est vrai que ça fait un peu
penser à Zançon euh de de la
légende et David n'est-ce pas?
Parce que là, on évoquait la la
situation de Neymar avec le
Brésil. Hum hum. Mais il faut
rappeler une chose, c'est que
il a jamais été en pleine
possession de ses moyens avec
la CSAO en coupe du monde En
2014, faut pas oublier qu'il se
fait massacrer
la colonne vertébrale, Derrière
le Brésil se fait voilà en cas
et en demi-finale sans lui, le
Brésil prend 71 contre la euh
l'Allemagne euh en
deux-mille-dix-huit il revient
à peine de blessure et il est
pas opérationnel, il il
s'arrête en quart de finale
encore contre la Belgique et là
euh lors de la la dernière euh
Coupe du monde, ben au début de
la compétition, il rechute mais
là on peut pas dire qu'il se
blesse parce que
quand vous vous blessez tous
les six parce qu'il a un jeu
qu'il expose énormément. Il a
des pieds très fins.
David beaucoup exposé mais se
blesse moins. donc c'est là la
différence. Est-ce que tu vois
ne serait-ce que les deux
dernières saisons de Vinicius,
est-ce que tu as vu comment
est-ce que il s'est comporté
parce que Vinicius subit aussi
les fautes les quatre c'est que
en fait beaucoup plus vraiment
fragile c'est comme du bambou,
ça se casse à tout moment et
c'est pour ça que quand tu me
parles de la motivation il faut
venir le motiver. Les
motivations qui vont faire qui
ne se cachent pas, ce ne sont
pas les motivations
dit oh oui peut-être il y a un
problème africain qui dit vous
avez ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
ce n'est on ne donne pas du
carburant à un chameau pour
porter sa charge. Si vous
voulez donc maintenant
aujourd'hui donnez à Neymar de
la motivation pour qu'il puisse
conduire l'équipe du Brésil eh
bien appelez douze coachs des
psychologues des psychiatres et
tout le monde a son chevet et
on laisse le football à côté
comme ça on va le motiver on va
dire euh il y a il y a quand
même une il a soixante-dix-sept
sélections il a
soixante-dix-sept ans. Non pas
encore. Euh ça ça serait dans
Tintin et il a 12quatre
sélections, c'est quand même
euh il a 124 sélections en
soixante-dix-sept buts,
excusez-moi. Euh et et et il on
savait pas il avait laissé euh
euh planer un doute sur est-ce
qu'il serait là à la prochaine
Coupe du monde hein, il l'avait
dit euh dans des médias
brésiliens il aurait quel âge?
Trente euh trente-quatre? Il a
31 ans, là? Trente-cinq. Il
aurait trente-cinq?
Trente-deux, trente-trois ouais
dans trois ans. Ouais. Mais
alors il a là là euh la
probable arrivé alors non
seulement des Henriques au
Paris Saint-Germain de
Ancelotti l'an prochain euh
avec la sélection, le motif
parce qu'il a dit l'avoir dans
l'équipe serait très important
mais rien n'est encore
confirmé, nous espérons quà la
fin de son contrat il rejoindra
l'équipe nationale, nous les
joueurs, nous le voulons euh
pour moi, pour Vigny, pour
évidemment ceux qui ont
travaillé avec lui donc c'est
c'est on revient à la
motivation euh et et à l'envie
de jouer. Motivation et sans
déresponsabilité se sentir
important, être la star au sein
euh au se au sein de l'équipe,
il était parti. Ouais. Du Barça
Pour aller au PSG pour être il
l'a pas eu Euh au Brésil on
voit maintenant que Ministre
est la star maintenant du
Brésil. J'étais au match contre
euh La Guinée à Barcelone. Euh
Vinici c'est la star absolue
maintenant de de l'équipe
nationale. Donc Neymar perd ça
aussi parce que il jouait aussi
en Espagne donc euh il y a un
sang on sent quà chaque fois
qu'il touche le ballon, que les
supporters brésiliens ils on
sent qu'il se passe quelque
chose. Euh et je reviens une
dernière fois sur ça. Moi je
pense qu'un départ il faut il
faut qu'il parte du PSG, il
faut qu'il parte du PSG
par an et je pense qu'après
serait euh, serait euh, serait
une possibilité, je pense que
euh, retournerait-il à
Barcelone? Eh bah, voilà. Eh
ben, justement alors, c'est une
très belle transition, allons-y
à Barcelone.
Alors la vie sans Messi euh
mais pas sans lendemain pour le
Barça, le Barça est redevenu
champion et ça faisait quatre
saisons que ça n'arrivait pas.
Entre temps ben du coup euh le
Real et l'Atlético hein puisque
ça se passe toujours à peu près
entre ces trois équipes ont
ravi des titres de champions
d'Espagne. Alors le FC
Barcelone se retrouve euh sur
euh aux avant-postes mais euh
est-ce que c'est avant tout?
Euh on avait beaucoup parlé de
son retour au club et euh on
voit le personnage derrière
vous pour ceux qui nous
regardent, François euh David
est-ce que c'est avant tout euh
grâce à Chavi et comme euh on
s'est amusé à le dire, Xavi
Chavit son oeuvre. Chavit son
oeuvre. Euh je dis toujours à
mes on avait parlé déjà euh
plus plus en direct je dis
toujours à mes amis euh sur
Barça heureusement que le Barça
de Chavi. Heureusement que le
Barça de Chavi et a eu de Xavi
cette année dans une année
compliquée avec les rumeurs de
d'achat d'arbitre, de de
pression de pression
extérieure, heureusement qu'ils
ont eu un joueur comme Xavi qui
connaît parfaitement le club.
Parfaitement la presse du club,
qui connaît parfaitement le
mode de fonctionnement du euh
très très haut niveau et qui
sait comment pensent les
supporters du FC Parson.
Heureusement qu'ils ont eu un
joueur, un entraîneur comme
lui, qui a été joueur il y a
pas longtemps, qui a été une
référence mondiale et euh qu'un
entraîneur qui je pense est
promis à un grand avenir. Il a
déjà au bout de quatre ans
senti du Barça ramené le titre
de champions d'Espagne et la
Supercoupe d'Espagne face au.
Un an et demi de travail hein
le Barça ça faisait quatre ans
qu'il euh euh qui ne gagnait
plus rien. Donc ils ont ça, ils
ont Xavi , ils ont un socle
vraiment sur qui ça s'appuyer
alors que d'autres clubs
recherchent un coach,
recherchent une une identité,
le Barça a au moins ça, le
Barça a perdu beaucoup ces
dernières années, mais au moins
ils ont un entraîneur qui a un
socle, qui est costaud et qui a
une vraie identité de jeu. Rémy
avec impatience nos
téléspectateurs que Rémy se
prononcent sur le Barça Rémy va
péter les plombs, euh on attend
Rémy, Rémy va exploser. Bon
alors en général, Rémy est le
roi du contre-pied hein, vous
aurez remarqué dans cette
émission Rémy sans et sans euh
sans sans vous sans vous
énerver contre le Barça . Il y
a quelque chose qui doit vous
plaire, c'est les résultats euh
pour ce qui est de l'assise
défensive de ce club absolument
incroyable hein François. Euh
ils ont encaissé cette saison,
seulement 20 buts en 38 matchs,
ils en ont marqué soixante-dix
et il y a eu 24 matchs de la
part du du Barça euh avec ce
qu'on appelle des clean sheets
c'est-à-dire sans encaisser de
de match. Ça veut dire que euh
de de but, ça veut dire que
Xavi il a commencé, ça vous
aimait bien ce genre d'images,
par faire une maison où il a
mis des fondations euh à
l'arrière? De la vive
Mourillon. D'ailleurs on l'a vu
contre le Real, c'était
Mourinho et là Xavi er
applaudissait. Bon, maintenant
quand c'est quand c'est une
autre équipe qui joue comme ça,
on dit oh non il joue pas le
bon jeu, ce n'est plus le Xavi
qu'on connaissait, ce n'est
plus à la York à la crevette,
ce n'est plus à la Pep
Guardiola, c'était maintenant
Chadi. Et il faut se dire que
c'est je ne peux pas aller à
contre-pied par rapport à ça.
Parce que j'ai toujours dit, il
faut bâtir par derrière. Parce
que justement le Barça avait eu
des difficultés au niveau des
recrutements. Regardez souvent
la défense du Barça on a quand
même eu des gens comme Umtiti.
C'est magnifique! On a quand
même vu une chanteuse française
qui a été recrutée là-bas!
Mireille, Mathieu, moi, pardon,
Jérémie, Mathieu. Vingt-2
millions d'euros! Je suis avec
euh oui mais mais tout ça là,
je t'ai dit! Ils ont été
réputés! Même les verbalaines
ont été recrutées dans la
défense du Barça, il y avait
Marc Barça qui était défenseur
au Barça et ce Barça là on ne
pouvait pas aller avec même
l'anglais a été recruté à
trente-cinq millions! Là-bas!
Après ils ont même dit que
peut-être euh le Tuchel
millions pouvant aussi jouer
défenseur défense. Aujourd'hui
c'est Barça a réussi à voir
Raoult qui est un défenseur qui
est très important, une
véritable tour de contrôle
parce qu'il faut savoir que le
Barça d'avant lorsque vous
regardez Pep Guardiola avait
bénéficié de cette tour de
confort qui faisait de telle
sorte que le Barça n'avait eu
en quatre ans avec 11 défaites.
C'était déjà parce que le Barça
parce que il défendait que le
ballon à l'époque le problème
c'est qui
la
profondeur, c'est-à-dire que
vous pouviez prendre le Barça
par derrière. Or, là-bas vous
aviez encore à une certaine
période une à six défensives
qui allait très très vite. Et
même encore les jambes. Baldé.
Baldé est là, il est très bon
et quand on voit aujourd'hui
Koundé ça ne ressemble pas aux
anciens défenseurs qu'on
pouvait avoir. Donc pour cette
équipe du Barça aujourd'hui, on
peut dire que. Gardien aussi.
Oui oui donc c'est ça mais
quand à dire que le Barça c'est
très très beau et qu'ils vont
revenir en Europe qu'ils vont
faire ceci. On a vu comment ils
ont fonctionné en Europe.
Voilà. Euh Frédéric? D'autres
commentaires puisque finalement
non mais ils attendent avec
impatience euh la saison
prochaine euh effectivement euh
il y a la Ligue des champions
parce que c'est une chose de
gagner la Ligue A hein mais ils
sont champions donc ils sont
qualifiés. Il fallait repartir
là aussi c'était les fondations
un petit peu hein euh oui. Mais
il y a beaucoup de questions
sur maintenant euh à l'assaut
de la Ligue des champions. Ça
fait un petit moment qu'on les
a en demi-finale. Alors ils ont
redoré leur blason finalement
euh dans au sein de de
l'Espagne et dans le
championnat espagnol.
Maintenant ce qu'on attend
d'eux c'est évidemment euh
l'Europe parce que cette année
euh ils ont même raté la Ligue
Europa hein. Ça les a la
priorité c'était la Ligue A
clairement pour le Barça donc
ils ont atteint ce premier
objectif. Maintenant
effectivement il va falloir
qu'ils redeviennent compétitifs
au niveau européen. Faut
rappeler quand même que cette
saison il tombe dans de la mort
avec le Bayern et l'Inter et
ils se font éliminer sur un but
refusé euh anormalement à Milan
hein parce que sinon il passe.
Donc si l'Olympique de
Marseille serait champion
d'Europe oui on en reparlera
une autre fois. Mais non comme
quoi il y a pas que le Barça
pas euh qui ne remporte pas. La
ligue Europa d'abord. Ah bah
après la Ligue Europa
effectivement bon ils tombent
sur le
non mais le le Barça clairement
avait un objectif qui était la
Liga, ils l'ont atteint il il
faut maintenant qu'ils
redeviennent compétitif au
niveau européen. Vous rappelez,
ils sont qualifiés pour la
Ligue des champions en tant que
champions en titre,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils seront tête
de série, donc ils auront
peut-être un tirage avec une
poule plus favorable et
derrière ils ont cette
expérience des échecs de la
saison écoulée parce que là
Xavi est en pleine
reconstruction, il avait une
urgence et effectivement il
pouvait pas parer à tout. Moi
je trouve que ce qu'il a fait
c'est quand même euh et je vais
pas paraphraser très bien il y
a quelques instants, mais
arriver à gérer ses anciens
collègues de vestiaires. Ouais.
Comme Sergio Busquet, Gérard
Pierre, Jordi Alba, Gérard
Pierre qui qui ont poussé à la
retraite en cours de saison,
reconstruire une défense, euh
mettre de côté aussi Éric
Garcia, euh qui était une des
recrues phares, un des grands
espoirs du club, enfin euh
faire doute, apaiser tous les
doutes arriver à faire ça en
quelques mois, c'est déjà
remarquable. Donc, j'espère que
la la poursuite va va être
récompensée au niveau européen,
mais c'est vrai que ce qui a le
chemin est déjà assez
extraordinaire. Justement la
poursuite euh François David au
niveau du recrutement on
imagine parce que évidemment il
y a déjà il y a les cadres, il
y a les jeunes mais euh on
parle de Guindoan qui euh
viendrait de Manchester City
jusqu'au Barça est-ce que alors
Neymar? Alors Hyper Busquets
déjà, comme euh important c'est
leur capitaine ils perdent un
cadre du vestiaire, on a vu
avec l'équipe d'Espagne
récemment il a encore
l'objectif oui c'est d'avoir un
joueur cadre au milieu de
terrain euh un peu comme comme
Gundogan qui sollicité mais euh
le Barça fait tellement le
forcing auprès de lui depuis
des semaines Xavi l'appelle
tout le temps que normalement
il devrait venir parce que si
jamais on rajoute Good Nogan à
Francky De Jong, à Pierry, à
Gavi, le milieu de terrain euh
du Barça c'est pas loin d'être
un un une meilleure des
meilleurs au monde avec la
défense qui est peut-être une
des meilleures au monde. Donc
effectivement qui est devant.
Et Lewandowski. Cette année
hein oui oui Avec des blessés
c' en championnat. Ousmane
Dembélé bien sûr C'était une
très belle équipe et avec un un
entraîneur qui sait où il va
euh, tous les espoirs sont
permis. Mais je pense qu'il
manque une star. Je manque
qu'il manque une deux enfin
quelqu'un peut-être pour
incarner comme la comme l'a été
Messi pendant des années et sur
le marché peut-être un des
joueurs les plus disponibles
peut-être si on fait fi de son
salaire qui est évidemment
quelque chose de d'immense et
surtout pour le Barça en ce
moment mais je pense qu'un
retour de Neymar on en a parlé
à Barça on avait parlé vous
vous l'avez retour de Messi
aussi. Oui bien sûr oui bah
Messi ne voulait pas attendre,
il voulait pas vivre le même
drame qu'il avait eu il y a il
y a deux ans euh il voulait pas
attendre que le Marseille pure
ses comptes par rapport à la à
la Ligue un, c'est très
compliqué. Et ça aurait bonne
idée, non? La nostalgie là de
faire revenir un Messi euh oui
non euh toujours bien d'avoir
Messi euh avec soi au Barça
surtout en plus là ils vont pas
jouer au Camp Nou pendant au
moins un an donc il va falloir
remplir le nouveau stade de
travaux. Et avoir une star
peut-être comme Neymar moi j'y
crois. Moi j'y crois. C'est
vrai que c'est très d'accord
avec ce que dit Xavi er, je
suis très d'accord, c'est
pratiquement impossible, mais
le Barça doit le tenter, le
Barça l'a tenté, le tente et je
pense qu'avoir un joueur comme
Neymar ça ça aiderait vraiment
tout le monde et et ça
apporterait ce petit quelque
chose je pense qui peut en plus
responsabiliser le le joueur
comme on en parlait. Eh bien,
les prochaines semaines nous
apprendrons donc si euh, euh,
Neymar choisit euh, ou de
retourner à Barcelone ou Luis
Henrique qui lui vient de euh,
revenir à Barcelone Neymar, il
aimerait euh, il aimerait
essayer il y a il y a de de de
saison. Il y a deux ouais.
Allez on continue on va parler
d'un capitan de l'équipe de
Belgique.
Il a claqué la porte rouge de
colère Thibault euh Courtois.
Il a le seum c'est peut-être
possible en tout cas le grand
gardien euh de l'équipe de
Belgique et non seulement parce
qu'il mesure euh deux mètres
mais on le sait, vous voyez ces
exploits chaque semaine c'est
évidemment avec le Real euh
Madrid eh bien le capitaine
n'admet pas que le brassard euh
ne lui euh ne lui revienne pas
lorsque euh celui qui le
possède euh qui le porte
actuellement, que Khevin De
Bruyne est absent. Ce qui a
donné que durant les deux
matchs d'éliminatoire au cours
de la semaine, pour le premier
avec l'Autriche, il était là,
mais donc c'est Romelo Lukaku
qui euh avait euh été nommée
euh capitaine et pour le
deuxième match eh bien il a
décidé de claquer la porte.
Alors euh l'excuse on a vu
qu'une photo a été postée sur
les réseaux sociaux avec euh un
bandage euh enfin plus ou moins
des trappes ou des stats je
sais pas. Strap pardon sur les
genoux, sur le genou euh droit
euh il euh était soi-disant
blessé. Ses camarades n'y
croient pas du on a d'abord le
le sélectionneur hein euh
Tedesco, Dominico Tedesco
l'italien qui s'est dit choque
de son départ euh comme ça. Ses
camarades de jeu aussi euh pas
trop solidaires hein euh
Vertonghen ou Yann Carasco qui
ont dit bon le brassard c'est
juste un détail finalement
quand on le porte mais on doit
se comporter en leader et
prendre ses responsabilités.
Est-ce que c'est un détail
vraiment? Rémy euh le brassard
pour un joueur titulaire dans
une équipe? Il a trente-et-un
ans il a cent sélections
le brassard peut créer beaucoup
de problèmes Euh vous savez les
difficultés des lions et la
table viennent d'abord de de la
gestion du brassard. Lorsqu'il
y a eu euh bien sûr euh cette
histoire entre Samuel Eto'o
Eric Aubert sans Xavi er et ça
a **** la coupe du monde 2010
alors que le Cameroun avait un
très bon effectif parce que le
sélectionneur n'avait pas pu
euh je et certains membres du
vestiaire bien évidemment, ça a
fait de telle sorte qu'ils
soient divisés, mais je ne
pouvais pas utiliser celle-là
comme un prétexte et pardonner
à Thibaut Courtois. Pourquoi?
Parce que autant j'ai critiqué
le comportement de nanas. Dans
les lions émontables, qui a
contesté l'autorité du
sélectionneur Hugo versant,
autant je dois critiquer le
gardien de la maison blanche
qui est excellent avec les
mains mais pas certainement
dans le comportement parce que
je ne comprends pas pourquoi
est-ce que quelqu'un Lukaku qui
a plus de sélection que lui,
cent-huit, lui il a 02 et il va
peut-être dire que il est
aujourd'hui un élément clé et
puis il va dire que non, c'est
à moi que devient revenir le
brassard il met à mal
l'autorité du sélectionneur de
ses camarades et pour moi j'ai
dit il doit être sanctionné
comme j'ai demandé qu'on en
soit sanctionné parce qu'il y a
un proverbe africain qui dit
quand le tour du bouc arrive
d'être égorgé, il montre
seulement son menton.
Ils sont ils sont pas tendres
euh Robson courtois, le gars
est arrogant, il n'aurait
jamais dû faire ça. Euh
Courtois est orgueilleux pour
Nino, le distinguer euh encore
un message à qui arrive euh à
euh Credo Best plus qui quand
même, Courtois mérite le
brassard plus que De Bruyne euh
bon. Forcément Regardez en
équipe de France après la coupe
du monde, lui Didier Deschamps
il a su gérer hein vous savez
qu'Antoine Griezmann aurait
bien aimé le récupérer, c'est
Mbappé il y a eu une discussion
et même Griezmann l'a dit en
conférence de presse qu'il
avait eu ça y est. Il avait pas
le choix
il avait pas le choix il y a eu
sur le sujet une très bonne
communication et de Mbappé et
de Deschamps et Griezmann a a
effectivement avoué qu'il avait
eu deux deux jours difficiles
quand il avait appris ça. Euh
là visiblement l'équipe de
Belgique c'est un joyeux boxon
hein parce que toujours. Euh il
y a beaucoup de très fortes
personnalités. Hum. C'est une
génération dorée qui finalement
n'a rien gagné. Euh il y en a
qui commencent à prendre leur
retraite comme euh Eden Hazard
euh voilà donc un certain
nombre de joueurs qui et
Thibaut Courtois qui a tout
gagné avec le Real Madrid et
qui a eu un rôle d'ailleurs
déterminant dans les succès
récent du Real Madrid se
retrouve dans une équipe
nationale où il est même plus
alors que c'est le meilleur
gardien du monde, il est même
plus le capitaine. Euh on peut
comprendre son seum façon et
façon de l'exprimer mais c'est
sûr qu'il rend pas service à
son pays en se comportant de
cette façon alors qu'il y a un
nouveau sélectionneur qui vient
d'arriver après les années
Martinez. Alors un peu le roi
de des des des déclarations des
attitudes un peu provocantes
Thibault Courtois, on se
souvient en en 208, euh après
l'élimination de de la Belgique
par la France en demi-finale,
il avait eu quand même euh
cette déclaration, on a
recherché, on a retrouvé je
préfère perdre avec cette
Belgique que gagner avec cette
France. Donc euh ça avait été
évidemment un peu, on, c'était
beaucoup moqué en France, euh
il avait dit c'est pas la même
équipe qui joue le mieux, qui a
perdu ce soir, mais enfin il il
il est il est aussi euh
peut-être un peu maladroit euh
il aurait peut-être peut-être
dû euh dix plus euh François
David? ? Vous parlez euh
peut-être avec son sectionneur
qui pour moi a pour moi à la
base c'est la faute de tes
secours. Le sélectionneur belge
qui a pas mis les choses au
clair, Xavier parlé de. De
Deschamps. Deschamps qui a une
expérience autrement plus
grande que euh le sectionneur
italien. Et je pense que euh
Courtois qui a une aura et
peut-être une expérience encore
plus grande que cet homme-là.
Il dit attends, moi je. Il a un
palmarès gardien au monde? Avec
Maignan je pense et euh il voit
ça, il voit lui donc tu laisses
aux nanas plus fort qu'on voit
cinq et dents
Rémy et Bien sûr que et euh des
autorités et je comprends le
seum, je comprends le seum de
Courtois qui a tout gagné déjà
qui est pas son meilleur ami et
problèmes de relation
conjugale. Ouais. Euh
typiquement belge qui voit ça
qui est pas là. Typiquement
belge. Non mais typiquement
hein et et et il voit ça,
Debruy n'est pas là euh moi
j'ai j'ai euh tout gagné, je
suis Thibaut Courtois, j'ai 31
ans, j'ai pas le brassard euh
je peux comprendre que si
jamais ça a pas été clair et
vraiment fait avant que le
sectionneur eh ben qu'on ait
cette euh situation tendue, je
comprends. Frédéric, encore une
réaction? Non, non. Euh Lukaku
nous sommes tous derrière vous,
nous dit euh Yafuma. Voilà.
Bon. Bien sûr. En tout cas euh
sera-t-il à l'euro euh
prochainement euh l'année
prochaine même s'il est un
petit peu sanctionné mais c'est
quand même un des plus grands
euh gardiens et puis on va lui
souhaiter aussi beaucoup de
bonheur parce que il doit euh
convoler dans quelques jours
avec une euh mannequin euh
israélienne qui s'appelle euh
Michel euh Jersey et donc euh
grand bonheur à ces nouveaux
mariés. Nous partons vers nos
cartons parce qu'on a plein de
choses à vous dire autour des
cartons aujourd'hui.
Carton jaune! Carton jaune
Carton rouge! Carton rouge!
Dans la confusion. Carton vert!
Extraordinaire! Rien à dire!
Honneur évidemment à vous,
chers auditeurs et internautes,
avec euh une sélection préparée
par David Finzel. Oh là là là
là! Rémy Ngono quand est-ce que
Cristiano Ronaldo va-t-il
s'arrêter? Deux-cents
sélections les gars, deux-cents
sélections. C'est historique,
le premier jour de l'histoire
du football à atteindre ce bar.
Respect à lui, chapeau à ce
grand monsieur du football. Et
moi qui suis un grand fan du
Barça je dirais que Messi est
un grand joueur mais Cristiano
Ronaldo n'est pas petit.
N'est-ce pas Rémy ? Chapeau!
Bonjour Café je m'appelle
Bachir et je vous appelle
depuis Dakar au Sénégal et là
je voudrais donner un carton
vert à l'équipe nationale de
foot du Sénégal pour avoir
donné une fessée, il faut le
dire hein, c'était une fessée
au Grand Brésil Et j'espère que
ça va ouvrir une nouvelle page
à au football africain pourquoi
pas amener la coupe du monde
c'est en Afrique
au léopard de la RDC pour leur
victoire face au Gabon.
Félicitations les gars et bon
courage. On espère que vous
allez gagner les derniers
matchs à domicile afin qu'on se
qualifie à la CAN en Côte
d'Ivoire. Bonjour bonjour
France. C'est monsieur depuis
la république démocratique du
Congo. Je donne un carton vert
à l'Espagne. Pour son trophée
en Ligue des nations après le
Portugal, la France, l'Espagne
et le troisième pays qui a
remporté la ligue des nations.
Carton vert bonne émission, bon
Café des sports. Salut Café des
sports depuis Cotonou carton
vert à Lucas Modric pour son
immense carrière euh même sans
titre avec la Croatie, chapeau,
chapeau respect. Bonjour. Café
de sport, moi c'est Philomene
des prix république
démocratique du Congo. Je donne
un verre à Khelian Mbappe qui a
marqué un but face à Grèce.
Bonne émission, bon café de
sport. Ciao. Bonjour
monsieur Rémy
a un joueur emblématique, un
danser, un animateur, un joueur
qui a mis la joie aux yeux des
des africains, des ganais,
l'international qui a pris sa
retraite le mercredi passé
devant Didier David merci à
Savoie bonne retraite et bon
vent. Bonjour. Radio FOOT
international, je m'appelle
Mamadou Sale je vous écoute
depuis le Canada. Aujourd'hui
euh j'aimerais donner un carton
rouge, un carton rouge aux
gladiateurs Cristiano Ronaldo.
Cristiano Ronaldo, c'est l'un
des plus grands joueurs de
l'histoire du football. Mais
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est
le bon moment qu'il parte et
s'il laisse la place aux
jeunes. Si
pour le faire de la place.
Merci, bonne émission. Salut
les co moi c'est depuis
le café des sport
ces initiatives vis-à-vis des
réfugiés de places nigérians au
camp des mineras ou ici à dans
l'extrême nord du Cameroun.
Elle qui a pris la peine de se
déplacer pour voir se réfugier,
les assister, jouer au foot
avec eux c'était une bonne
c'était une bonne initiative à
sa. Allez ciao. Voyez Rémy hein
vous avez des des corps
religionnaires qui sont euh
fantastiques qu'il nous a
envoyé les illustrations parce
que lui était au match et un
grand bravo donc aussi à qu'on
a déjà reçu dans dans cette
émission. Ils sont pas tous euh
d'accord avec Rémy
et et téléspectateurs et avec
notre vedette africaine. Rémy
ça sera à vous l'honneur
aujourd'hui, nous avons un
document d'archives. Un carton
vert. Carton vert euh, je crois
même que c'est sa couleur
préférée pour un un très très
grand joueur euh qui est sous
le les feux de l'actualité là
depuis quelques jours euh
quelques heures euh et il joue
au basket. Victor Wemb le
français qui a été drafté comme
on dit par euh les Sports euh
la NBA aux États-Unis, il va
jouer à San Antonio euh prodige
de 9 ans mais avant hein on le
voit là la nuit dernière à à
New York euh avant de jouer au
basket euh il a joué au foot et
Souheil Khedir qui est là en en
régie réalisation nous aide à
préparer euh l'émission, ben il
l'a croisé plus d'une fois
parce que sur cette photo euh
il y a un de ses enfants à
Souheil et puis vous voyez
celui qui est le plus grand
déjà c'était en
deux-mille-treize il avait euh
dix ans à peu près il était
Victor Wemba Niama du club du
Chesnay. Le Chesnay FC
soixante-dix-huit donc il a
commencé par le foot avant de
faire du basket et d'ailleurs
je crois que ça l'aide
énormément pour ces mouvements
et parce qu'il est super
fluide. Ouais ma Niama est
d'ailleurs un joueur comme Akim
on a qui était du du Nigéria il
y a 20 ans maintenant pareil
avait commencé par le foot il
avait aidé à être le pivot le
plus technique de la de la NBA
donc euh tous les basketteurs
doivent commencer par le foot
pour être euh ouais dans les
buts à la Thibaut Courtois là
Il fait deux mètres vingt-trois
aujourd'hui quand même hein
raconté qu'on lui demandait
toujours euh l'identité de son
jeu en disant non mais là là
celui que t'as là dix ans il
dépassait les autres, il était
le double des eaux mais euh un
jour soit elle va nous laisser
tomber pendant un un vendredi,
il ira voir un match à nous
raconter. Mais mais on a
Khelian Mbappé et on va avoir
pendant euh alors ceux qui se
blessent mais voilà prochaines
années deux figures euh en plus
par euh par le le basket.
Allez, on continue dans cette
émission. Euh Rémy quelle est
la couleur de votre cartouche?
Oh là là! Rouge! Mais c'est
bientôt la fin Rémy ah oui oui!
Rouge pour euh le gouvernement
centrafricain. Spa! Parce que
les fauves ont perdu mais parce
que justement les fauves
manquent d'infrastructures.
Vous vous rendez compte que un
grand pays comme la République
centrafricaine est bien un seul
stade est là et pour 20 000
places, on ne parvient pas à
rénover ce stade haute
dimension internationale, on
peut faire déplacer tout un
gouvernement, on loue un stade
au Cameroun, ça coûte cher et
on vient rendez-vous compte
pour un match des des défauts.
Voilà. Le chef de l'Etat est
là. Deux ministres d'État sont
là et sans pour autant oublier
que nous avons dix ministres,
dix-sept députés, un
ambassadeur, un consul, 19
membres du cabinet du premier
ministre de ceci et cela. Et en
Mais ils perdent de l'argent,
ils perdaient, ils perdaient
cela et attendez, quand je suis
un au lieu de demander tout
simplement un proverbe africain
qui dit on élève pas les
moutons sans construire
l'enclos. Ça c'est logique.
Bien sûr. François David ? Oui.
Quelle est la couleur de votre
carton? Carton rouge. Carton
rouge, alors on a parlé
beaucoup de de l'Arabie
Saoudite ces derniers temps euh
des transferts euh mirobolants.
Mi volant des salaires
extraordinaires et euh j'ai
appris en lisant l'équipe euh,
il y a quelques semaines eh
bien que euh, un club qui
voulait acheter Messi il y a
quelques temps devait euh,
sept-cent 000 euros ou un
million d'euros, un agent de
joueur français et fait un
transfert il y a 10 ans et
depuis laissé couler la la euh,
situation malgré toutes les
relances, les choses
diplomatiques et je trouvais ça
absolument honteux parce que
euh, ça montre bien ce que
c'est l'Arabie Saoudite et le
Qatar euh, au niveau du foot.
Quand t'es une grande star on
te paye énormément, on te donne
tout, on te fait unir
trente-et-1 quelqu'un de lambda
on t'oublie et euh, ça m'étonne
pas euh, ce qui se passe
maintenant jamais il va se
faire payer au passage hein
euh, je moi je connais pas plus
que ça mais euh, moi je parlais
avec euh, on est dans la com.
C'est ça mais et moi je parlais
avec quelqu'un qui connaît très
très bien le Qatar et le
Moyen-Orient il me disait bon,
les Qataris, les Saoudiens ils
se considèrent comme ça avec
les Américains, nous les
Européens on est en dessous et
euh, il y a plus rien. Donc
voilà, moi j'aimais pas cette
euh et ça s'appelait comment du
football apparemment. Xavier
Barret ? Oui, carton vert,
carton vert, un petit pays qui
n'a encore jamais participé à
l'euro, il y avait les
éliminatoires euh en début de
semaine, le Luxembourg qui
allait gagner en
Bosnie-Herzégovine, deux zéro,
une euh une euh un succès qui
est qui est déjà le le deuxième
dans dans ce groupe, le
Portugal va sortir en tête,
mais il y a deux places
qualificatives. Et le
Luxembourg a déjà fait des très
bonnes performances ces
dernières années, en
travaillant bien avec les
jeunes. Euh comme président de
fédération a celle l'ancien
sélectionneur qui est resté 16
ans en poste donc il travaille
sérieusement et ils seront
peut-être récompensés comme
l'équipe surprise qualifiée
pour le prochain souviens
qu'ils avaient battu la France
une fois en France à Toulouse
hein si je ne le le le le le
Luxembourg. Match nul. Match
nul ouais. Bon en tout cas ils
avaient fait un un bon
résultat. Le carton de Radio
FOOT est vert hein nous on aime
bien le vert et il va? Eh ben
c'est logique, un lion, un lion
de la Terranga, non c'est pas
le votre ami. Idrissa Ganaghee,
le milieu de de terrain au lui
cent-quatre sélection euh pour
son action surtout hors des
terrains puisqu'il est euh,
l'ambassadeur de et le
cofondateur de l'association
caritative FOOT il est arrivé à
Cotonou pour le match Bénin
Sénégal et il est allé au
centre national hospitalier
universitaire de Cotonou euh,
pour euh, donner du matériel,
un matériel dédié aux enfants
malades du sida. Voilà. Il agit
dans l'humanitaire euh, et
ensuite il joue avec le Sénégal
euh, a perdu ce jour-là euh,
qui a fait match nul euh, avec
le Bénin. Et c'est la fin de ce
Café des Sports. merci à tous,
à la semaine prochaine pour la
dernière.